VIKAS SAINI: Today,
we'll discuss
how Lowe's built an
Enterprise-class, centralized
price management solution
on Google Cloud Platform.
My name is Vikas Saini.
And I'm an Enterprise Cloud
Architect at Google Cloud.
Joining me today
for this session
is the vice president of
merchandising technology
at Lowe's Companies, Ron Baker.
Thank you for joining, Ron.
How are you doing today?
RONALD BAKER: Hey, Vikas.
Doing very well.
Excited to be here
today and share
what we've been working
on in our pricing space
and how we're
investing and really
advancing our technology.
So it should be a great session.
I'm looking forward to it.
VIKAS SAINI: Great.
So Ron, before we start, can
you share some information
about Lowe's with us?
RONALD BAKER: Absolutely.
Lowe's is a very
exciting company,
overall one of the top Fortune
50 companies with stores
in both the US and Canada.
And we have a global
workforce as well.
And one thing that really
excites me about Lowe's,
just the investment
that we're continuing
to make in technology
and how technology
is really key to helping the
company to achieve our goals.
And I feel very blessed to
be leading both our product
and engineering teams for
the merchandise technology
portfolio.
Just a lot of great
things going on.
And we're going to talk
today about pricing,
just one of many areas that
we're continuing to invest in.
And we continue to seek and hire
top technology talent as well.
And we're expanding in both
our US and Bangor locations.
So technology has just never
been more exciting than now
within Lowe's.
And it's a great
journey to be on.
One other thing I'll
call out is that we're
in our second year of
a multi-year technology
transformation.
And we're building a
Lowe's tech hub right here
in Charlotte, North Carolina.
So a lot of growth going on.
And looking to hire close to
2,000 additional technologists
for that facility.
And just excited about the
growth and the opportunity that
we have go on here
within Lowe's.
VIKAS SAINI: Yeah, no, I agree.
Lowe's is a very
exciting company.
And we are very thankful
for the partnership.
So let's look at the
agenda for today.
So we'll briefly discuss the
centralized price use case,
go over the solution that was
created for this use case.
We'll also talk
about the benefits
that Lowe's was able to
achieve after implementing
the solution.
We'll briefly touch the
road map for the next phase
of the solution.
And then finally, we'll wrap up.
So let's start with
the use case overview.
So Ron, I'll ask you this--
can you please tell us about
the use case and any pain points
that you are trying to
address with the solution?
RONALD BAKER: Yeah, let's--
I'll kind of walk through
it and three main areas.
As you can imagine, Vikas,
for a company our size,
the number of products,
the channels that we serve,
the customers that
we serve, pricing
is a extremely complex area.
And we had-- to
start off with, we
had this challenge where we
had multiple sources of truth
for our prices.
And this created a lot of issues
with just how we were managing
across the various channels.
And so we had to spend some
time to really understand
that complexity.
And we knew we needed a
single source of truth
to really take us to
where we wanted to be
and managing this
more effectively.
The second thing is we
needed to really put together
better visibility and controls
in place so that we're
more consistent with our prices
and how those prices are set up
across all the channels.
That was another
significant gap that we had,
as we were looking at just
some of these use cases
and the challenges that
were in front of us.
The third is really
around we had
to improve how we executed
our price changes.
We needed to leverage a
single source of truth,
but then take that to
the next level in terms
of how do we execute more
effectively and really getting
the right prices in the right
place at the right time?
As you can imagine, speed was
really the key here, right?
How do we do that in
the most effective way
to really take us to
where we needed to be?
So as we went through and
understood these challenges,
these were really
foundational to trying
to determine what's the right
technology that we choose.
And my hat's off to our
product management organization
and working with our
business partners
to really outline these
challenges in a way
that our technology teams could
really take these and determine
what is the right technology
solution that we need in order
to enable this?
And when you look at the
complexity of the business,
with our price, as
I've mentioned before,
this was a difficult task
that we had in front of us.
And we were really diving in
to understand these challenges
and figure out how do we
move forward to solving them
in the most effective way?
VIKAS SAINI: It's a very
interesting use case.
Let me ask you this--
why did you choose Google Cloud
as a platform for the solution?
RONALD BAKER: Yeah,
our team really
stepped back when we
were looking at, again,
these use cases
and the challenges
that we had in front of us.
And we went through
an evaluation
of various technologies.
And one thing that is
really part of our culture
is we go through
proof of concepts.
And in this case, we actually
ran two things in parallel.
We were looking at all
open-source technology.
And we we're looking at
some of the components
within Google Cloud to really
kind of test this out and see
how does the
technology really help
us to solve the business problem
and in the most effective way?
And so the teams did
this very rapidly,
went through these
proof of concepts.
And this is just
culturally what we
do as an organization to ensure
that what we're selecting
is the most effective.
And so we ended up selecting
Google Cloud, and really
three main reasons I'll describe
here of why we did that.
First, you got to
think about having
the right architecture
that enabled flexibility
was key behind this.
And when you take
something like pricing,
which is a very, very
critical component
to your retail business, and
looking at how you scale that,
we needed the right
architecture and flexibility
to enable us to do that.
That was number one.
Number two, leveraging some
of Google's managed services,
like Spanner and Pub/Sub, was
another key element to this.
And one of the things that
when we look at our engineering
team, we want to make sure that
we're building and delivering
new capabilities for the
business as much as possible.
And by leveraging
Spanner and Pub/Sub,
we didn't have to
spend a lot of time
on and worry about having
to upgrade the underlying
technology to support
the overall solution.
So it really enabled
our engineers
to focus on building
out these capabilities
and driving value for
the business, which
is what we want.
The third thing I'll call out
is around some of the analytics.
And by having our data in
a more centralized location
and solution, we're able to get
a lot more valuable insights
into just how we're
performing and where
are we at in the lifecycle.
And so that was really the
third area that was key for us.
And understanding
that performance
and how we take immediate
action is really
what helped us to
make that decision.
And Google was really
key to helping us
get there as soon as possible.
So again, I'll just say hats
off to our engineering teams
and the Google team
partnering together
to get us to this
point and helping us
as we've made this selection
to really move us forward
in the most effective way.
VIKAS SAINI: All right, so
you heard from Ron on the use
case and the pain points.
Now, let's discuss a solution
that was built to solve this.
So this solution
is built leveraging
some of the technology from
our retail common services
platform.
So before showing you
the actual architecture,
I'll quickly go over
some of the design
principles for this solution.
One of the key architecture
principle of the solution
is that it's completely
event-based architecture.
So most of the traditional
architectures are batch-based.
All of the upstream
events are actually
written to the central
event's source.
So as we would expect,
the event source
has to be highly available.
This event source
then publishes events
for other downstream
systems to use.
You're also able to filter the
events into a central system
for fast querying from other
applications that need access
to this data.
In parallel, you can
also load the events
from the system for analytics
and learning and analysis.
So if you want to give access
to the data for your data
engineering team or your data
science team to build models,
to do any sort of
analysis or recording,
they're able to do that without
affecting the core system.
And lastly is that you can
also play back the events
from the archive if needed.
So if you ever need
to go back and look
at the chronological order
of events, how they occurred,
you're able to do
that with this system.
So let's look at
the architecture.
So this slide shows the
architecture for the solution.
So as you'll see, there's
a lot of detail here.
I'll go over some of
the key components
at a very high level.
The first step is
price optimization.
So this is where we
classify price for items,
such as base price, markdown
price, discounts, er cetera.
So as you would expect,
every item or every SKU
needs to have a price
optimization process.
After the price
optimization, the next step
is data transformation,
so ETL, if you will.
So we use Dataflow for
data transformation.
And we also have a parser to
format and parse the data.
Once the data is transformed, it
is ingested into Cloud Spanner.
So Cloud Spanner has the
benefit of True Time.
And what that means
is that it easily
lets you add a
globally-consistent timestamp
for all of your events.
So the benefit for
the solution is
that this establishes a ground
truth of the order of all
of your messages for all time.
This means that you can make
downstream assumptions anchored
on that ground
truth, which solves
a lot of complexity for
dependent systems and services.
Up next are the
event-based triggers
that pull this data
into the messaging
queue from Cloud Spanner.
And our messaging
queue is Cloud Pub/Sub.
So this is the layer
where the records
are filtered and written
to a centralized messaging
queue pops up.
And the benefit of this is
that the multiple subscribers
can be registered to get data
from this messaging publishing
queue.
One of the main subscribers
is the master publish view.
The data or the
events are loaded
to a corresponding
low-latency database
or materialized view
for easy query access.
This has to be a really
low-latency database,
so think of it like an
in-memory database or a really
low latency NoSQL database.
It just depends on the
size of the database.
We've actually tested
this pattern for millions
of records and
millions of products
and this holds pretty well.
And one of the main reasons
why we're able to do that
is because we are
able to separate
the writes from the reads.
In parallel, we also
have the Archiver,
which writes these events to
a global archive called Cloud
Storage in a compressed state.
And then corresponding to
the Archiver is a Replayer.
So Replayer then
reads the records
in order of the
long-term storage
and then decompresses
them and loads them
into a new cloud upstream.
So if you ever need to go back
and look how the events were
loaded into the system, how
you got certain data, what
was the chronological
order of all the events,
you're able to easily do
that with the Replayer.
And lastly, we also
have the ability
to make one-off price
changes using the price UI.
This price UI goes through
the centralized API
and writes information
into Cloud Spanner.
And once the information
is in Cloud Spanner,
it goes through the
same process of pushing
the data to master publish
view and to the Archiver
or that we just discussed.
So hopefully this
gives you an overview
of the solution that was
created to solve this use case.
All right, so let's move on to
the benefits of the solution.
So Ron, let me ask you this--
now that the solution's
live, can you
please share some
of the benefits
that you've seen so far?
RONALD BAKER: Absolutely.
The first thing
that we accomplished
was really getting
that centralized view
of all the key components
for pricing for all channels.
And as I mentioned
earlier, Vikas,
that was one of
the challenges we
had, of just trying to manage
this across multiple systems.
And getting that single view
was absolutely key to us
in achieving that benefit.
The second is
increasing our speed
to market for the price
changes and enabling just a lot
more efficiencies for how
we're making those changes.
Again, you go across
multiple systems.
It takes a lot of
time, takes a lot
of coordination in
getting those centralized,
improves our speed to
market, so we can do that
much more effectively.
And then a third
that I'll call out
is really around the
ability to be proactive
and just managing
our price changes
and knowing that our price
changes have been executed.
As you can imagine,
our store associates,
they're dealing with
a lot in the stores,
just making sure they're
serving customers.
So when we're thinking
about the pricing
and how we send our prices
down to the stores to execute,
we want that to be as
efficient as possible.
And one of the key
benefits here is
it's made us a lot
more effective with how
we prioritize those changes
and how much we're sending down
to our stores so
that they can be
more effective at implementing
the necessary prices
that we actually need.
So just tremendous
progress here.
And definitely getting
a lot of benefit out
of the capabilities that
have been put in place.
VIKAS SAINI: So now that you're
getting all these benefits,
Ron, what are your plans
for the new features
and functionalities that you are
looking to add to the solution
as we move forward?
RONALD BAKER: Yeah,
we're going to spend
some time focused on
really these three
main areas I'll walk through.
First is around our price
performance and some
of our price change analytics.
When we look at the
number of price changes
and how those prices are
performing in the markets, how
our customers are
responding, that's
one area that we
want to continue
to build out and enhance more
for the overall solution.
The second area is around
price governance and some
of the audit capabilities.
Again, I'll reflect back
to some of the complexities
we had with multiple
systems and how
do we have the right visibility,
the number of users that
can make changes to our prices.
It was very complex and
very difficult to manage.
And so this foundation
we have in place now
has really positioned
us well so that we
can more effectively
track and control
how those prices are handled.
And so we'll continue to
enhance that functionality
as we move forward.
And then the third area
that I'd call out just
around price testing
and measurement.
And how we put our
prices in market
and getting the results back
and measuring the effectiveness
of that is absolutely key.
And we'll leverage this
foundation in place
to build upon so that we get
more effective measurement
and understand how we're
progressing going forward.
So ultimately, we want to ensure
that we're putting forward
the best price for our
customers at the right time,
at the right channel.
And the foundation
we now have in place
is going to be key
to help us continue
that priority and that journey.
VIKAS SAINI: All right,
so as you heard from Ron,
this pattern provides
many important benefits
over traditional architecture.
The first one is
global consistency.
So Cloud Spanner has the
benefit of True Time.
So it easily lets you add a
globally consistent timestamp
for each of your events.
So this establishes
a ground truth
of the order for all of
your messages at all time.
And you can have your
downstream systems work
with that assumption,
which is a huge benefit
and solves a lot of complexity
for those downstream systems.
The next one is
high availability.
So multi-region writes
are necessary for systems
that run in multiple
places, east or west,
disaster recovery.
But multi-region writes are
also great for sending events
from a single system
in the data center
to multiple systems that run
in the stores in this example.
Or vice versa-- so for things
like price, inventory tracking,
real-time sales metrics,
this is important to have
high availability
across the board.
And, as you mentioned
earlier, we've
actually tested this solution
for millions and millions
of products across channel.
And the solution
holds pretty well.
So if we have some
very stringent SLAs
and you want to make sure that
the performance doesn't degrade
when you are using millions
and millions of record,
then this solution is probably
the right one for you.
And then as Ron mentioned
earlier as well,
is this lets you focus
on the strategic tasks.
And the dev teams are
focused on building business
logic or the business
value directly associated
with the use case and
not worry about some
of the operational tasks of
keeping the servers up, scaling
them up or down, because the
system takes care of that.
This results in quicker time
to market and much lower
total cost of ownership
for the solution.
I want to, again, thank
Ron Baker, vice president
of merchandising technology
at Lowe's Companies,
for sharing the information
and his thoughts with us.
And to you, thank you for
listening to our presentation.
Hope you found the
content useful.
RONALD BAKER: I just want
to say, add to that, Vikas,
thanks for the partnership
here with Google.
And really appreciate
the opportunity
to speak to what we've been
able to accomplish here
in the pricing area.
Like I mentioned in
the introduction,
Lowe's is advancing our business
with technology like never
before.
And I'm excited to see so many
capabilities, like pricing,
enabled, and proud of what our
team's been able to accomplish
with this modern technology.
So I hope all of you as well
got some valuable insights
into the content.
And I want to thank all of
you for your time today.